that's the attorney representing
Adrienne's trust I'm required to read a
prepared statement Cecelia although our
relationship was far from perfect I
thought that you would talk to me rather
than run away okay what happened to him
he cut his wrists for his final wishes
you're getting five million dollars
contingent of course on the fine print a
campaign ruled to be mentally
incompetent
it just doesn't make any sense what
Adrienne wouldn't kill himself
listen getting your freedom back okay
don't let him haunt you I'm scared you
don't have to be scared of him anymore
he was a sociopath
completely in control of everything he
said that wherever I went he would find
me walk right up to me and I wouldn't be
able to see him buta someone's sitting
in that chair I found something I can't
prove what I'm experiencing you need
help
Adrian is dead
I wouldn't you sell us today he's not
dead
I have a pile of ashes in the box that
would disagree with you he has figured
out a way to be invisible only thing
more brilliant than inventing something
that makes you invisible was coming up
with the perfect way to torture you even
in death Adrian's true genius was how he
got in people's heads don't come any
closer
I'm not crazy you're saying the person
trying to kill you
is in the room right now but we can't
see them
[Music]
there you are
[Music]
you